ça ne te dérange pas mais non pas du
tout regarde j'ai beaucoup de mecs alors
2 3 4 5 6 le compte y est c'est bonjour
docteur bonjour factor pardonnez moi
mais j'ai des clients
[Musique]
encore une belle journée pas vrai et oui
facteur c'est bien triste pour sur julie
je ne vous comprends pas vous n'aimez
pas le soleil aussi beaucoup mais je
n'en profite guère
je suis enfermé toute la journée dans
mon kiosque à toutes les caramels
souvent à une promener ou beignets
bonjour messieurs bonjour bonjour mon
chèque snot à écouter facteurs ne
commençait pas il fait très beau jetant
pleine forme je n'ai pas du tout envie
de disputer au contraire qu'est ce que
j'ai fait je vous rappelle que je tiens
beaucoup à ce qu'on appelait monsieur du
snob pour sûr monsieur du snob
je ne voulais pas vous vexer parce que
nous sommes devenus des grands amis que
vous avez acquis le droit d'une point
respecter le nom illustre que je tiens
de mes ancêtres
mais loin de moi une pareille penser
monsieur duchesneau enfin mais il fait
si beau dans l'île aux enfants que cela
me donne envie d'embrasser tout le monde
a trimé il a peu tenu et oui factor vous
vous avez de la chance de vous promener
toute la journée au soleil
pour sûr j'aime beaucoup mon métier et
moi même à très chers amis vous m'avez
l'air fort triste puisse faire quelque
chose pour vous rendre service vous êtes
gentil monsieur du snob mais vous n'y
pouvez rien mademoiselle julie aimerait
bien pouvoir aller se promener et se
baigner
est ce possible mais ma très chère amie
faut y aller sans plus tarder je me
ferai un plaisir de vous remplacer cet
après midi vous feriez ça messieurs du
stop non je vous le promets oh mais
c'est vraiment très gentils
non tout à fait naturel voyons mais
monsieur du jeune homme
savez vous rendre la monnaie au moins
mon chère amy je vous rappelle que je
les connaissances approfondies de
mathématiques modernes d'algèbre de
géométrie différentielle de
mathématiques analytique le gars tu sera
suffisante et très simple le prix et sur
les boîtes et les beaux qu'on ne vous en
faites par la charmée par exemple merci
beaucoup encore je reviens pour la
fermeture du kiosque très bien au revoir
et amusez vous bien julie un bon eh bien
mon cher sinon je vais aller voir
françois monsieur pardon monsieur du
snow pour pardon monsieur du snob mais
que voulez vous c'est sûrement dans la
chaleur oui je sais je sais je sais
françois facteur dit vous savez une
lettre pour moi non non j'ai juste le
paquet pour casimir par cette très
embêté ans il s'agit d'une lettre très
importante qui aurait déjà dû arriver
par le courrier d'hier rang tour sur
elle sera dans le bateau tiens quand ce
taux fort en fin d'après midi
il faudrait vraiment que j'avais jusque
là bas facteur vous rendez moi service
vous me remplacer juste le temps que
j'aille au port aux bons sur je finis ma
tournée françois et m'asseoir un petit
peu au frais me fera le plus grand bien
un gentil je tâcherai de ne pas être
trop long ne vous en faites pas pour les
tout notre temps merci factor
[Musique]
c'est à casimir au t3 mais tu manges
prouve que tu arrives qui tue est énorme
bonjour je t'en prie casimir wassa la
meilleure alors gérer ville que se
passe-t-il
je n'en sais pas plus que vous monsieur
du snob casitas restée mais que tu
arrives qui la coiffe habitués affreuse
aujourd'hui mais je ne trouve pas
amusant du tout tu joues les imbéciles
mais je sais parfaitement content comme
tous les deux au lieu de rire casimir tu
ferais mieux de nous aider un homme et
pas du tout non non il fait trop beau
non je préfère aller me promener sur la
plage est allé tromper mais mignon petit
pied dans les vagues fraîches viennent
se briser sur les rochers gourbin en
attendant 15 me prend au pack est
attaqué pour moi oui
et regarde le teint brun c'est un taquet
qui vient du japon du japon terre
donnez-moi sa facture aux merci-facteur
au revoir monsieur du jeune homme et
amusez vous bien
c
mon cher emile que se trouve-t-il dans
le paquet que vous avez donnée à casimir
pour sûr je ne sais pas du tout monsieur
du snop
mais c'est des mains vous le savez rien
du tout mais faudrait 1000 écoutez
monsieur du snop je ne regarde pas dans
les facs et que je distribue moi ce ne
serait pas bien mais ce n'est pas ce que
je voulais dire mais je ne veux pas
quitter mon kiosque on ne sait jamais
prévenir quelqu'un à l'improviste et
puis j'ai première mademoiselle julie je
voudrais bien savoir ce que contient le
paquet moi aussi moi je te dis stop je
ne peux pas quitter cette chaise j'ai
promis à françois cazis nier ne fait pas
de bruit
mon ami au rapport c'est un animal qui
est dans ce pack r ouais c'est mon
nouveau compagnon je présume mon cher
ami que c'est un petit chien
moi je parierais plutôt pour un bébé
chat c'est un animal très dur qui vient
se blottir dans mes bras à ça ça c'est
sûrement une habitude de chara wifi il
aime bien se cacher tous les jours à la
même place pour observer ce qui se passa
à vos chères emile je regrette pour vous
je crois que j'avais raison
ce cachet tous les jours à la même place
pour observer ce qui se passe je
d'études de chiens il adore chasser les
mouches et les papillons hoversen alors
ça c'est vraiment une habitude de chat
pour sûr de gagner
oui mais le moment où je le préfère
c'est lorsqu'il se couche sur le dos et
qu'il remue en l'air ces huit petites
par lui huit petites plaques
alors ça ça ne peut pas être un chat non
ça c'est vrai et ni non plus un chien
d'ailleurs au mais enfin pourquoi parlez
vous toujours de chat ou de chien
enfin regardez je vous le montre
c'est une araignée qu'elle est mignonne
mais pourquoi sont ils partis en courant
comme ça oh je ne vais pas pouvoir aller
à la plage il va falloir que je garde
tout seul à la fois les ballons de
françois et le kiosque de julie
[Musique]